اذا مشاهدينا من استديوهات الرياض الى
استوديوهات دبي وهذه الخامسه وانا ميسون
عزام نكمل معكم ونستمر في تغطياتنا تغطيه
العربيه لحظه بلحظه داعيات الزلزال المدمر
والذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا لا تزال عمليات
الانقاذ مستمره بحثا عن ناجين تحت الانقاض
وسطى ظروف طقس قاسيه ابقوا معنا في
الخامسه
هذا وطلبت سوريا تفعيلها اليه الحمايه
المدنيه التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي مسؤول
اداره الازمات في المفوضيه الاوروبيه قال
انهم تلقوا طلب المساعده من سوريا وان
الدول الاعضاء ستساهم في تقديم المساعده
المزيد معنا من مدينه الدانه في ريف ادلب
الصحفي محمد الاشقر اهلا بك محمد خبرنا
اخر المعلومات ما هو متوفر لديك من
معلومات وكيف هي الاوضاع
طيب الصوت غير واضح محمد الصوت غير واضح
ربما نعود اليك بعد قليل
صوت غير واضح يتقطع
نعم هل تسمعيني
جرب احسن هلا بس جرب
نعم نعم كنت اتحدث على ان حجم الكارثه هنا
في شمال سوريا هو اكبر من القدرات فرق
الدفاع المدني والفرق التطوعيه التي تشكلت
من الاهالي المدنيه طبعا نحن نتحدث عن
الاخر عدد وصلت
اليها اعداد الضحايا نتيجه الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب المنطقه هو اكثر من 2000 الف
ومئتين واربعين حاله يسات واكثر من
2750 حاله اصابه والعدد مرجح للاستياد
بشكل كبير نتيجه حجم الدمار وعدد الابنيه
التي انهارت بشكل كامل ولا يزال الى حد
هذه اللحظه مئات المدنيين تحت الانقاض
ينتظرون انتشالهم من تحت هذه الاقطاب طبعا
الدفاع المدني والفرق التطوعيه والفرق
الشبابيه يعملون
ابسط الامكانيات بادوات بسيطه جدا هذا
الامر الذي تسبب بزياده المعاملات طبعا
اليوم وهو اليوم الثاني على حادثه
الزلزال الى حد هذه اللحظه لا يزال لا
يزال الفرق تنتشر ضحايا احياء من تحت هذه
من تحت الالقاب ولكنهم ولكنها التاخر على
انقاظها ليتسبب في حالات الوفاه طبعا اذا
تحدث قليلا عن بوضع الانساني للناجين فنحن
نتحدث عن كارثه انسانيه في الحقيقه هنا في
شمال غرب سوريا
الكارتفاع قدره المنظمات الانسانيه
المنتشره الجميع يعمل باعلى طاقته ولكن
عدد
النازيين وعدد النازحين اللاجئين الى
مراكز الايواء المؤقته بعد الضخم بحاجه
التدخل دولي وبحاجه تدخل في من المفترض
محمد بدات تصل مساعدات او لا
نعم طبعا قبل قليل اليوم اصدر اداره معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا بيانا نفت فيه
دخول اي قافله مساعدات الى حد هذه اللحظه
لم تدخل اي مساعدات دوليه واماميه الى
شمال غرب سوريا الطاقات التي تعمل الى حد
هذه اللحظه هي طاقات سوريه من الاهالي
المدنيين الموجودين في المنطقه بالاضافه
للفرق التطوعيه وفرق الدفاع المدني التي
تعمل باعلى طاقاتها الى حد هذه اللحظه لم
تدخل اي قافله
مساعدات من خارج سوريا طبعا
البوابه الحدوديه هي فقط لنقل
جثامين السوريين الذين توفوا في الداخل
التركي في جنوب تركيا ونقلها الى سوريا
ليتم دفنهم هنا في سوريا اما عن عن
المساعدات فلم تدخل الى حد هذه اللحظه اي
مساعدات من خارج سوريا ماذا عن الاصابات
حجم هذه الاصابات
نعم كما ذكرت لك لا يوجد عدد دقيق عن عن
عدد الاصابات ولكن اخر رقم وصلنا له هو
2000 وسبعمائه وخمسين اصابه واكثر من
بس انا النقطه هي طبيعه هاي الاصابات
الموجوده نعم نعم جميعها هي هي اصابات
اغلب الاصابات التي تخرج من تحت الالقاب
تكون اصابات حرجه نتيجه التاخر في عمليه
انتشالها من تحت الانقاض بسبب عدم توفر
المعدات والادوات الحديثه المخصصه للتعامل
مع مثل هذه الكوارث يعني الى حد هذه
اللحظه كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل يتم انتشال
ضحايا جرحى احياء ولكن يعني يتعرضون
للوفاه اثناء نقلهم الى المشافي نتيجه
التاخر عن عن عن اسعافهم بسبب ضعف الامك
ضعف الادوات
محمد خبرنا خبرنا عن المستشفيات العامله
وما الذي تستطيع ان تتحملوا حتى الان وان
كانت قادره على الاستمرار وان كان ايضا
بالمقابل فيه مشافي ميدانيه او غيره
نعم يعني في الحقيقه جميع المشافي في شمال
غرب سوريا هي مستنفره بكامل طاقاتها جميع
العاملين في المجال الطبي
والمجال التمريض مستنفرين ايضا محاولين
اسعاف ما او انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه هنا في
الشمال السوري طبعا المشاب اغلب المشافي
مقتظه
بالجرحى ولكن
الهم الاكبر هنا في شمال غرب سوريا
والكارثه الكبرى الحقيقيه هي في حقيقه في
انتشال الضحايا وقدرت فرق الدفاع المدني
والمتطوعين على انتشال الضحايا من تحت
الانقاب نحن نتحدث عن كارثه انسانيه كبر
في شمال غرب سوريا يعني لا تستطيع اي
كاميرا ان تنقل حجم الكارثه ولا يستطيع اي
صحفي ان ينقل حجم الكارثه بكلماته طبعا
بدي اسال
ان سامحت لي ان انوه الى ان هناك احياء
بالكامل مدمره سمحتي لي ان اسلط الضوء على
مدينه جنديرس في ريف مدينه عفرين هذه
المدينه منكوبه احياء كامله باتت تحت
الارض تحت
ديانه مباني كثيره عشرات المباني سويت في
الارض مئات الاهالي لا يزال لا يزالون الى
حد هذه اللحظه تحت الانقاذ ان تحدثنا عن
عن منطقه في مدينه حارم ادلب ايضا نحن
نتحدث عن كارثه انسانيه عشرات المباني
سويت في الارض والى حد هذه اللحظه يوجد
عشرات الضحايا تحت الانقاذ ان تحدثنا عن
مدينه ارمناز عن مدينه مللت عن مدينه
الاقارب عن مدينه سرمدا يعني في الحقيقه
يصعب ذكر جميع المناطق التي تعرضت لهذه
الكارثه الكبرى اعيد اكرر الوضع في شمال
سوريا بحاجه تدخل اممي بحاجه التدخل دولي
بحاجه امداد الفرق فرق الانقاذ بمعدات
متطوره مناسبه للتعامل مع مثل هذه الظروف
المعدات من جهه وايضا دعم للاستمراريه من
جهه اخرى وهذا السؤال يتعلق بانه هل هناك
من يتحرك لدعمهم ومدهم بالماء والغذاء حتى
يستطيعوا ان يستمروا بالعمل لانه بحسب ما
افهم العمل خلال اليومين دون انقطاع محمد
نعم نعم يعني
في هذه النقطه الى حد هذه اللحظه لم تدخل
اي مساعدات من خارج سوريا انا اتحدث على
الارض من قبل من قبل السوريين انفسهم يعني
هل في تحرك شعبي
نعم الامر الذي يساعد
على استمرار العمل هو حاله التكاثف الشعبي
الموجوده هنا هناك
مئات المطاعم التي قامت بتقديم الوجبات
هناك مئات محطات الوقود التي تكفلت
بامداد الاليات التي تعمل على الانتشار
الضحايا من تحت الانقاب
بالوقود هناك
الكثير من الفرق التطوعيه والمنظمات
الانسانيه التي تكفلت بامداد العاملين على
انتشار الضحايا من تحت الانقاض بالماء
والطعام ولكن الجميع يعمل باقصى طاقته
طاقاته ولكن كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل حجم
الكارثه هنا في شمال غرب سوريا اكبر بكثير
من قدرات الفرق الموجوده او المنظمات
الانسانيه العامله هنا او حتى الاهالي
المدنيين كان معنا من الدانه في ري محمد
الاشقر شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
ومعنا من سرمدا بشمال سوريا احمد يازجي
وهو عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني السوري
اهلا بك استاذ احمد ابدا بما انتهى به
ضيفي قبل قليل عندما قال بان حجم الكارثه
اكثر من قدرات الجميع ومنها الدفاع المدني
خبرنا
بكثير من اي قدرات ممتلكها كدفاع مدني او
شتى
المنظمات العامله في شمال الغربي سوريا
حجم الفارسي الكبير وحجم التدمير كان
طبيعي الجغرافيه للزمار كان تغيير جدا حيث
كانت على اغلب منطقه شمال سوريا مباني
احياء كامله بالاضافه الى عده مباني قدمت
بشكل جزئي والاف المباني التي تصدعت الى
الاندفاع المدني على انتشار العالقين تحت
الانفصال في ظل الظروف المناخيه الصعبه
الان نحن تقريبا في وقتنا بعد صغيره درجه
الحراره الان
في ساعات الليل تكون دون صفر فدرجه
الحراره
قليل جدا
صعب من الاعمال ايضا
تقلص من اعمال الناجين تحت الانفار منذ
عده دقائق اثارنا الفريق الذي يعمل فيه من
اخراج شخص على قيد الحياه هذا هذا الامر
الذي يجعلنا مستمرين رغم الامكانيات
المتوفره بين بين يدينا على اخراج
العالقين من تحت الانقاظ
لانه قبل ساعه ايضا ونصف كنا على الهواء
مباشره وشاهدنا بتركيا ايضا
امكانيه انتشال امراه كانت لا زالت على
قيد الحياه السؤال هو لازال هو هناك امل
والى متى يعني هل سنبقى ويمكن ان نطمئن
الناس انه لازلنا بمرحله انتشال الضحايا
ام انه يمكن ان نقفز فجاه الى قضيه
الانتشار الجثث فقط
نحن من مبارح ودانا عده نداءات على عمليه
الاسراع دخول المساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا لكي نتمكن من الافراد جميع العالقين
تحت الانصار وهم على قيد الحياه الى همزه
هذه اللحظه تكون فرقنا باخراج عالفين على
قيد الحياه
نحن ما رح نفقد الامل ولكن الوقت في دعمنا
بنعرف
الهزات الارتداديه اللي عم بترافق رافق
زلزال من من لحظات الاولى كمان هي
تسبب خطر على جميع العالمين تحت الانقاظ
بالاضافه على الفرق العامله مثل اللي
بيعرف انه شمال سوريا هي منطقه
الطائرات الروسيه والسوريه فاغلب المباني
المتواجده لديها هي متصدعه غير ان ذلك هو
الزلزال الذي حصل ادى الى تصدع كبير
فهنالك ايضا من النزاه الاعتداديه التي ما
توقفتنا بعد حدوث الزلزال ولكن الى حد هذا
المقطع التركيز بالنسبه لكم الان اين
وبالمقابل كيف يمكن العمل بالتوازي ما بين
البحث عن ناجين وانتشال الضحايا وما بين
الحديث عن انه الاعلام السوري يتحدث عن
300 الف شخص في سوريا اضطروا لترك منازلهم
بسبب الزلزال هل هناك من امكانيه للتعاطي
مع الحالتين
احنا عم نحاول ننتجه على الجانب بشكل
متعلق بعمليات البحث والامطار على عمل
خروج جميع العالقين من تحت الانصار وهم
على قيد الحياه اما بالنسبه للشقه المتعلق
بالمدنيين المتضررين للصراحه والاسامي الى
حد هذه اللحظه لا يوجد مراكز
تاوي اليها هذا هؤلاء المدنيين الذين
خرجوا من من الزلزال لا يوجد
اماكن سوى هي مبادرات شعبيه من قبل
المدنيين من جهات محليه
بالنسبه للدعم الدولي الذي كان يتكلمون
عنه منذ يومين الى الان الى الان هي عباره
عن وعود
ننتقل لحد هذه اللحظه نعود نامل ان تكون
هذه النوعود تترجم على ارض الواقع
وبالسرعه القصوى لكي يتجدد العمل لدينا
العالمين وهم على قيد الحياه
او قائمه المتطلبات بالنسبه لكم
المتطلبات بالنسبه لنا هي المعدات التي
تساعد على عمليات البحث المنقاز
وهي معلومه لدى جميع الدول بالاضافه الى
الاليات ثقيله التي تعمل على
انتشار
الاسقف
والاوزان هي ابرز الاحتياجات ولكن اذا من
بعد شكل اغاثه والانسان للمدنيين حاليا
المتواجدين عده عوائل مدنيه هي موجوده
بالطرقات في عده عوائل موجوده حاليا
مستقله سياراتهم موجودين مني حاليا
بالساحات العامه للحدائق كمان هدول الناس
اللي
الزلزال
لمساعده لدعم وشكرا جزيلا لك احمد ياسر
عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني السوري على
هذه المشاركه ومباشره مشاهدينا الى كلمه
لمنسق الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في
سوريا
بالاضافه الى ذلك فاننا على استعداد من
موقعنا
لزياده وجودنا والوصول الى الاشخاص الذين
هم بحاجه الى مساعده هذه مساله لكن من هذا
الجانب فاننا نعمل
مع كافه المحافظات سعيا
لوجود منافذ دخولي الى الشمال الغربي
وبالاضافه الى ذلك فاننا نعمل
قريبا على ان على ان نضمن ان هذه
الامدادات التي قدمناها كما تعلمون سوف
سوف تنتهي
وهناك مخازن في دبي تحتوي على بعض المعدات
الطارئه
والمؤن الضروريه التي لابد من ايصالها الى
هناك واعمل ما امله هو انه لمره واحده
ان يجعل كافه الاطراف مصلحه الشعب تتغلب
على كافه المصالح الاخرى وخاصه ان الكل
يطالب بالعون واهيبوا بكافه الشركاء ان
يعملوا على تسهيل
هذه المساله بصرف النظر عن كافه الضغوط
لان الامر يتعلق بالشعب اننا مستعدون في
مساله
تقديم المؤن التي قد تستغرق بضعه ايام
لوصولها لكافه المناطق ونعلم على زياده
المؤن والامدادات
ولكننا بحاجه الى مزيد من الدعم اود ان
اقول مساله اخرى ان الارقام لم يتم ذكرها
ما نحتاجه قد يكون اقل مما يرد الحديث عنه
اسمعوا اسمعوا البعض يتحدثوا عن ارقام قد
تصل خمسه اضعاف ما قد نحتاجه بصوره فعليه
لابد لنا من اجراء تقييم فعلي وحقيقي
للاحتياجات ولابد لنا من ان
نعالج كافه هذه المسائل في سياق
في سياق معاناتنا مع كافه المشاكل العلقه
الاخرى سؤال ايضا
تابع هل لك ان تذاكرنا ما هي التحديات
التي واجهتكم في مساله
تامين الامدادات عبر الخطوط والحدود بحيث
يتم
بحيث يتم تامينها عبر كافه المنافذ
دعيني اجيب على هذا السؤال
في في غضون الاشهر السبع
السبعه او ثمانيه الماضيه استطعنا ان نؤمن
امدادات
عبر الخطوط
وبمقدورنا فعل
بمقدورنا تاميني المزيد منها لكن هناك
احتياجات لابد من معالجتها ومقدور زياده
حجم القافلات من اربعه عشر او خمسه عشر
شاحنه الى اعداد اكبر اننا جاهزون لكننا
بانتظار كافه الشركاء لتسهيل هذا الامر
الحكومه هي المشكله
لم اقل هذا لم اقل ان الحكومه هي المشكله
الحكومه وما تقوله بان لديها كافه
التسهيلات
وكنا قد حصلنا على بعض خطابات التسهيل من
قبل الحكومه وكانت قد وعدت في اليوم الاول
وبعد يومين تم تسهيل الامر للوصول الى
اللاذقيه ومن اجل اجراء عمليات تقييم
واسعه
وقد حصلنا على الضوء الاخضر
لقد ذكرتم للتو ان عمليات الدعم تلك قد
تستمر لبضعه ايام فقط ما هي الاشياء
الاخرى التي هي
بامس التي هي مثل حاجه عليها وما هي اوجه
النقص الشديد في عمليه الغوص ثانيا عندما
تتحدثون عن ان الحكومه السوريه هي ليست
المشكله
وانها وعدت بتسهيل الامور بالنسبه لكم من
اجل تقديمي وتعزيزي الجهود الانسانيه هل
لديكم اي خطر في هذا الخصوص فهل لديكم
مثلا مساعدات انسانيه عبر الخطوط على
المدى القريب ويوم الامس الممثل الدائم
للحكومه الذريه قال ان بعض بعض
القوافل التي سوف تتوجه الى سوريا ليس
بمقدورها ان تحطها في مطار دمشق هذا قد
يكون مشكله على بالنسبه للعمليات او
المصادر التي قد يجب التي يمكن ان تخصص
لمساعده الشعب السوري
سوف ابدا ومن ثم احيل الكلمه الى مهند
سوف ابدا بالوقوف على الاحتياجات
الاحتياجات هي المنطق هي المساله الحساسه
فنحن بحاجه الى غذاء وماء
ومولدات لاننا في اماكن قد لا توجد فيها
مولدات الكهرباء بالاضافه الى المساعدات
الطبيه
[موسيقى]
علاجات للصدمات
النفسيه والحمايه بعد ذلك
اننا نعمل في بيئه
تعد هشه للغايه سلفا بحيث تفتق الى الوقود
والبنيه التحتيه تعاني وعانت كثيرا
والمنازل هناك
كانت تعاني منذ فتره طويله وقد يكون هناك
عمليات تهاوي لهذه المباني لذا فاننا
بحاجه الى معدات ازاله الانقاض البحث
واننا في في مكان يضرب فيه الشتاء البارد
لذا فهناك حاجه ماسه للبطانيات وكل ما
يخطر في بالكم عندما تكونوا في اوضاع صعبه
مشابهه
ولعل هناك نواحي اخرى مثل المساعدات
الطبيه اننا بحاجه لتسهيل هذه الاعمال هذه
منطقه مجددا
عانت معاناته من الصراع بين اطراف مختلفه
نحن نعمل هنا ونسعى للتنسيق بيني وبين
مهند
هو مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق شؤون
الانسانيه ومع المقر الرئيسي والوكالات
الاخرى المختلفه لاعطيكم مثالا حول ما حدث
اليوم وقد يكون هذا سؤالا وجيها اليوم
سوف يكون هناك وجود لمجموعه كبيره من
المنظمات الدوليه مثل
الصليب الاحمر الدولي
والمساله هي ليست نقص او معاناه في او شحف
المساعدات بل هي مساله تنسيق وسوف اجيب
اجيبك على مساله المده الزمنيه
برنامج الغذاء العالمي لديه ما يكفي
لاطعام مئات الالاف الاشخاص خلال اسبوع
اتحدث عن اسبوع من الزمن اما السؤال
الثاني
واذا ما كانت هذه الطائرات سوف يسمح لها
ان تحط في المطار قلت لكم واذكركم بان
الحكومه قد وعدت في بعض الاجتماعات بانها
سوف تسهل الامر لكن هذا السؤال يجب ان
يوجه مجددا الى الحكومه السوريه ولم نحصل
على اجابه حتى اللحظه مهند
نعم شكرا مصطفى لابد لي ان اقول ما هو
واضح
ومعروف لدى الجميع ان مساله تامين هذه
المساعدات والغوث هي مساله معقده معقده
حتى قبل
الزلزال فهي بحاجه الى مستويات متعدده من
التنسيق بين المنظمات الغير الحكوميه
والجهات المانحه وهي ليست عمليات مباشره
بالاضافه الى ذلك هذه المنطقه عسكريه
يتوجب علينا العمل بداخلها المساله ليست
يسيره كما قال مصطفى نعم الامم المتحده
لديها عزيمه والقدره على تنفيذ تلك المهمه
لكن الامر لا يتعلق فقط بالامم المتحده بل
يتعلق بالاطراف الاخرى التي يجب التنسيق
معها ونحن
لن نقوم
الا ببذل كافه الجهود المطلوبه لكن الكلام
اسهل من التنفيذ لك وفي ظل هذه الظروف
نستطيع ان نفعل المزيد عبر الخطوط وعبر
الحدود
شكرا
سؤال لكل من المتحدثين
ما هي الخطط الاوليه للامم المتحده في
مساله معالجه
الصدمات وتقديم المساعدات العاجله لانقاذ
حياه البشر في ظل
العقوبات التي فرضت على الحكومه السوريه
هذا السؤال الاول السؤال الثاني هل لكم
الارقام
الصحيحه عن اللقاحات التي سوف يتم تقديمها
في تلك المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره الحكومه
ان مصطفى لم يعد معنا
لا انا موجود مازلت
هناك ثلاثه اسئله
المساعدات المنقذه للحياه
واللقاحات والكوليرا بالنسبه للمساعدات
المنقذه للحياه فالامم المتحده لا تستطيع
ان تقدم الا ما تحصل عليه
الامر يعتمد على ما يصلنا وما سوف نقدم
تلك هي الاشياء التي يجب ان نطلبها هو ان
نسلط
الضوء على هذه الاحتياجات
وقد تكون مطلوبه حتى بعد 72 ساعه في عقابي
وقف في عمليات البحث والانقاذ في الانقاذ
المساله والاوضاع
التي نعاني منها
تنطوي على نقص الوقود قبل الحديث عن
العقوبات وغيرهم نحن لا يوجد لدينا
المعدات الكافيه واللازمه بحيث
يمكننا اصلاح بعض المعدات مثل
سيارات الاسعاف وغيرها
من المركبات
سوف نعمل على تامين كافه هذه المتطلبات
وسائل الاعلام يقع على كاهلها دور كبير في
مساعدتنا بدلا من الضجيج الذي نسمعه فانتم
شركاء لنا
العقوبات
جل ما استطيع ان اقوله ان هذه هي الاشياء
التي لدينا
فاننا بحاجه الى مولدات واننا بحاجه الى
اصلاح مضخات المياه والنضمن بان هناك
استثباب للامن
وبمقدورنا التحرك بسرعه من اجل تقديم
المساعده
نطلب منكم ان تساعدونا
لتحركي بسرعه وسوف نتحدث في مرحله لاحقه
عن السؤال الاكبر بالنسبه للعقوبات بشان
الكوليرا
اعتقد باننا حصلنا حتى اللحظه على مليونين
جرعه لقاحات
في
الشمال الشرقي
وفي المناطق الخاطئه لسيطره الحكومه
السوريه
وسوف نحصل على 1.6 مليون جرعه
لمناطق الواقعه في الشمال الغربي
هذا كان كله قبل الزلزال والان وبسبب
ذلك الزلزال وبسبب تجمع الناس في بعض
المناطق فان مصادر المياه قد تاثرت علمت
بان هذا قد اصاب بعض المناطق مثل حلب
واللاذقيه وغيرها لذا فاننا سوف نواجه هذا
الامر مجددا
المياه
التي قد تتاثر
وصرف الصحي في المناطق المكتظه
لذا قد نرى ازديا في حاله الكوليرا في هذه
المناطق لذا فاننا بحاجه للمزيد اننا
بحاجه لكل شيء من كل شخص
مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذه الكلمه
ايجاز حول الدور الذي تقوم به الامم
المتحده طبعا كنا نستمع الى منسق الامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في سوريا وطبعا
تحدث عن الافتقار الى المعدات الكافيه
لجهود الانقاذ في سوريا
مشاهدوا ماساويه يصعب تقبلها وحقائق علميه
تفوقها صعوبه فالسؤال الذي يتبادر لاذهان
الكثيرين لماذا كان هذا الزلزال مميتا
تركيا تقع على خط صدع زلزالي رئيسي في
العالم والزلزال الذي ضربها في السادس من
فبراير يعد الاكثر تدميرا منذ عقود تسبب
في صدع يمتد طوله لما يزيد على 100
كيلومتر بين الصفيحه الاناضوليه والصفيحه
العربيه علما بان التصادم بين الصفيحه
العربيه وصفيحه اوروبا واسيا ينتج عنه
اعنف انواع الزلازل واكثرها تكرارا وفق
علماء الزلازل حصيله القتلى المروعه نتجت
عن عوامل عده اولها الحجم الهائل للزلزال
ثانيها حقيقه انه وقع على عمق ضحل نسبيا
من السطح قدر باحد عشر ميلا فقط وكذلك
قربه من مناطق ماهوله بالسكان بكثره
فالزنزال تركز على بعد 26 كيلومترا تقريبا
شرقيه مدينه نورداي في غازي عنتاب وعلى
عمق نحو 18 كيلومترا عند فالق شرق
الاناضول واطلق الزلزال موجات باتجاه
الشمال الشرقي ما تسبب بحدوث دمار وسط
تركيا وسوريا
زلازل كهذه اي التي تتجاوز قوتها سبع
درجات يقل حدوثها فبلغ عددها نحو 20
زلزالا على مر التاريخ زلزالان فقط سجلان
نفس القوه بين عامي 2013
و2022 لكن الطاقه المنبعثه عن الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا تزيد بمقدار 250
مره عن مثله في ايطاليا عام 2016
وفي غضون ذلك قال رئيس لجنه الاغاثه
العليا في سوريا حسين مخلوف قال ان فرق
الانقاذ تواجه ازمه في نقص المعدات
اللازمه لانتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاد
مطلوب سرعه وليس تسرع لان هذا العمل الفني
دقيق نحن نتحدث عن ارواح تحت الانقاب
وبالتالي التعاطي معها بمعدات خاصه من
خلال
بواجر او تكسير او او من خلال روافع هذا
الامر بالتاكيد لدينا نقص بالامكانات ولا
ولا يعني ندعي غير ذلك لكن تم تامين ما
يلزم من خلال زج كل الطاقات في مواقع
الاحتياج
عرض حزين المنطقه والدفاع مدني
اياك امم
ومع استمرار عمليات الانقاذ لليوم الثالث
زار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مدينه
قهرمان مرعش التي ضربها الزلزال جاءت هذه
الزياره بعد ان عبر العديد من سكان المدن
التركيه المتضرره عن غضبهم من السلطات
جراء وصفوه بالاستجابه البطيئه وغير
الكافيه يذكر ان الرئيس التركي يواجه
تحديا كبيرا في مجال الانقاذ واعاده
الاعمار والذي سيطغى على الفتره التي سبقت
انتخابات مايو
يتم
نبذله قصار جهودنا ونوجد في كل المدن
المتضرره
مؤسسه افات تتراس عمليات التنقيب والانقاذ
وهناك وزير يتابع كل المجريات في اليوم
الاول واجهنا بعض المشاكل في الوصول الى
المدن اليوم تحسن الاداء وسنحقق الاعمار
خلال عام كما حصل في حوادث زلازل سابقه
ولنترك اي مواطن في الشارع
المزيد معنا من الحدود التركيه السوريه
الصحفي ابراهيم الادلبي اهلا بك ابراهيم
خبرنا عن المعابر هل فتحت لم تفتح هالمره
اي من المساعدات لانه المعلومات متضاربه
بهذا الاطار
اهلا وسهلا بك وبجميع المشاهدين المعابر
وعلى اللسان الجهات الرسميه اعلانات
استعدادها وجاهزيتها وفرقها من اجل استلام
السيارات التي من المتوقع ان تصل الى
المعابر بعد ان يقوم الجانب التركي بشق
الطرق وفتحها باتجاه المعالج المدن
المنكوبه جنوب تركيا هناك مشكله في ايصال
المساعدات وخاصه ان القوانين الاماميه
كانت فقط تدعم معبر باب الهوى بالقرب من
ولايه هاتاي التركيه التي ايضا شاهد
التضررا كثيرا وخروج الكثير من الطرق
السريعه عن الخدمه لذلك
السلطان التركيه لمنح تصريح لبعض المعابر
الثانويه من اجل توجيه المساعدات الاضافيه
من القريبه من منطقه غازي عنتاب اتحدث عن
معبر باب السلامه عن بعض المعابر التي
كانت تستخدم بوقت سابق من اجل نقل
المصابين والجرحى من المدنيين باتجاه
الاراضي
انا اسال هذا السؤال لانه البعض نتحدث
بالامس انه هناك شاحنات مكدسه ممنوعه من
الدخول انت تقول انه لا لم تصل لانه
الطرقات تحتاج الى فتح والى ترميم
نعم صحيح الطرقات تحتاج الى فتح والى
ترميم قد تكون الشاحنات مكدسه بالمطارات
او بالمستودعات مستعده للتحرك ولكن لا
يوجد هناك اي حركه للشاحنات الاغاثيه
باتجاه معبر باب الهواء او حتى المعابر
التي كانت قد تم اعطاءه صلاحيه ادخال
المساعدات منها من المتوقع ان تصل قريبا
ولكن هذا يعتمد على ايضا الطقس الجوي الذي
تعاني من المنطقه الجنوبيه من تركيا
والشماليه من الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا
كان هناك عاصفه ثلجيه ادت الى شلل في
الحركه في جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا قبل ان
يضرب زلزال وبعد ذلك كان هناك عاصفه مطريه
كل هذه الظروف الجويه لا تساعد بحركه
المساعدات طبعا هناك تاخير كان في
الاستجابه ولكن بالنهايه الجميع يسارع
يسابق يسابق الوقت كل ثانيه نقوم بتوفيرها
قد تؤدي الى انقاذ روح من تحت الالقاب
لذلك عمليات البحث عن الناجين ما تزال
مستمره من قبل فرق الدفاع المدني
وسنتحدث عن هذه النقطه ولكن بالامس اذكر
تحدثنا عن انه احد الانهر ارتفع منسوب
المياه فيه وبالتالي كان هناك مخاوف من
غمر بعض المناطق هل من معلومات حول هذا
الموضوع هل حدث اي شيء بهذا الاطار نعم
كنا نتحدث الامس عن نهر العاصي بريف حماه
والممتد ايضا في تاريخ ادلب الغربي لا
يزال نسبه المياه مرتفعه طبعا تدفقت الى
جانبي النهر كان هناك تحذيرات للسكان
والسكان المخيمات القريبه من نهر العاصي
بريف حماه بريف ادلب الغربي في محيط مدينه
جسر الشغور بالابتعاد في حال لوحظ ايضا
ارتفاع اخر لانه لم تلاحظ او يلاحظ او
يسجل اي ارتفاع جديد لنسبه المياه الاولى
والفيديوهات التي حصلنا عليها المدنيين
يؤكدون ان الحاله لا تزال شبه مستقره ولكن
بالنهايه لا يمكن الحذر على ما يحدث داخل
او في باطن الارض لذلك هناك الحيطه والحذر
من المدنيين والمراقبه المستمره للاث
الجانبيه التي احدثها الزلزال ان كان على
مستوى متابعه الانهر او حتى ايضا المباني
المختلئه التي تصدى الجراء عمليه الزلزال
الاول والثاني والحزات الارتداديه طيب شو
المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول عمليه
الانقاذ وانتشال ان كان الضحايا من هم على
قيد الحياه او انتشال الجثث اي نعم لنبدا
بالعمليات والمعمليات المركزه بشكل اكثر
في منطقه جنديرس تحديدا في المدينه التي
اعتبر اكثر من 80% من هذه المدينه مدمر
الابنيه مدمره على رؤوس قاطنيه اي ان مئات
العوائل ما تزال عالقه تحت الانقاص في
مدينه جنديرس والتي اهمت فرق الدفاع
المدني والمتطوعون وكل من يستطيعوا يملك
الاليات للمساهمه والمساعده هناك بعض
القوافل المساعدات الداخليه التي توجهت
باتجاه المنطقه جنديرس ساتحدث عن
المساعدات المدنيه قام المدنيين بجمع بعض
الاغذيه وبعض الحاجيات وارسالها ايضا
استمرت تستمر عفوا الى هذه الاثناء عمليه
انتشال الجثث من تحت الانقاص في مدينه
سرمدا على الحدود السوريه التركيه ايضا في
حارم وسلقين تستمر عمليه انقاذ المصابين
في سلقين ايضا منذ ساعات ماضيه تم انقاذ
احد المدنيين من تحت الانقاذ وهذا ما دفع
الامل لبقيه الفرق بالاستمرار بالعمل بشكل
مكثف من اجل البحث عن ناجين هناك طبعا كما
تحدثت سابقا واكرر تعتمد عمليه البحث في
هذه المرحله على البلاغات المؤكده من اجل
مسابقه الوقت ومن اجل محاوله انقاذ من هم
تحت الانقاذ بالنسبه لي العوده الى مدينه
جنديرس تحديدا والتي حتى هذه الاثناء
تمكنا من احصاء 580 واكثر بقليل مدني
كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم في هذه المنطقه جراء
الزلازل بالنسبه لاعداد
المدنيين المصابين والذين اخرجوا منذ
بدايه الزلزال الى الان تجاوز 2700 مدني
كانوا قد تلقوا العلاج العلاج المتفاوت من
علاجات اوليه الى علاجات الى علاج الكسور
او حتى الصدمات طبعا اجهزه كبير منهم تم
نقله الى شمال سوريا باتجاه منطقه
المخيمات من اجل البحث عن قليل من الامان
والابتعاد عن المباني المختلئه والمتصدعه
طيب اذا ما تحدثنا الان عن من اخلو بيوتهم
والاماكن الايواء اللي يقال بانها غير
متوفره هل هي متوفره باماكن معينه دون
غيرها او لا الحال كما هو في كافه المناطق
المنكوبه
نستخدم المثل العام الاول انه الحال كله
من بعضه ومنه ننطلق ان بعض المدن كمدينه
مركز مدينه ادلب وايضا بعض المدن الكبيره
التي ساهمت خطوط النقل او وزاره النقل
المتواجده هناك بتسخير الاليات كملاجئ
مؤقته في ساحات عامه بعيدا عن المبادئ عن
المبانية والمتصدئه لتكون محطه اولى مكان
الراحه للمدنيين المتضررين ايضا
المخيمات العشوائيه المنتشره في الاراضي
الزراعيه في عمق ريف ادلب ايضا ساهمت
باحتواء عدد من المدنيين من الذين فروا
باتجاه المناطق او او الاتجاه العراء
والعراضي الزراعيه والقسم الاخير الذي وصل
الى الحدود السوريه التركيه اماكن ايواء
منشاه او انشات حديثا من اجل استيعابهم لم
يتم تسجيل اي نقطه ايواء منشاه فقط تم
الاعتماد على منشات
كمنشات عامه كالمدارس او حتى المستوصفات
والنقاط الطبيه التي تحدثت في وقت سابق ان
هناك مناشدات كانت لاخراج بعض المصابين
منها من اجل فتح او اعطاء مكان او مساحه
لمصاب اخر لذلك تحدثت ايضا واعيد واكرر ان
هناك فئه من المدنيين كانوا قد لا اقول
فقط الامل او وصلوا الى مرحله الياس ولكن
الظروف الجويه اجبرت عددا منهم بالعوده
باتجاه المنشات السكنيه المتصديه في مح
منهم للبحث على قليل من الامتعه او ايضا
استخراج بعض ما يلزمهم من منازلهم ولكن ما
يزال هناك تخوف من ردات اهتزازيه خاصه انه
منذ قرابه الساعه او 45 دقيقه كان هناك
هزه ارتداديه في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
من سوريا شعرت فيها عدد سكان عدد من
المناطق ولكن حتى الان لم نسجل انهيارات
او اضرار بالنسبه للهزل الارتداديه
الاخيره كان معنا من الحدود التركيه
السوريه الصحفي ابراهيم الادلبي شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والمزيد معنا من القاهره ريم ندى المتحدثه
باسم برنامج الغذاء العالمي اهلا بك ريم
بدايه هل وصلتم الى تقرير شامل ربما
يعطيكم فكره عن وضع الماساه على الارض او
لا زلتم في مرحله التقييم
هي الماساه واضحه طبعا لكل الاشخاص
العاملين في الاغاثه وايضا حتى للناس
الذين يتفرجون على التلفزيون حاليا حتى
عمال الاغاثه انفسهم حتى موظفين برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه المتواجدين في غازي
عنتاب لانه برنامج الاغذيه العالمي له
تواجد في غازي عنتاب كما له تواجد في كل
انحاء سوريا وايضا
يوصل المساعدات الى شمال شرق
شمال الشمال الغربي ايضا خاصه في منطقه
ادلب ولكن يعني التقييم الاولي لبرنامج
الاغذيه العالميه ان هناك
نصف مليون شخص برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
يهدف او الوصول الى النصف مليون شخص
لتقديم المساعدات على مدار ثلاثه والاربع
اشهر القادمه حتى الان امس فقط تم توزيع
مساعدات غذائيه من وجبات ساخنه
حصص غذائيه جاهزه للاكله لانه الاشخاص ليس
لديهم
وين ريم وين استطعت الوصول اين استطعت
الوصول
في حالات تم توزيع وجبات ساخنه للمتضررين
من موجه الزلازل وايضا تم توزيع في
اللاذقيه وتم توزيع الان يتم ايصال
مساعدات غذائيه في تركيا
في
جنوب تركيا الى
المخيم مخيمات اللاجئين الموجوده التي بها
ايضا مواطنين اتراك هناك
17000 حصه غذائيه الان ويهدف البرنامج الى
الوصول الى 300 الف شخص
بالمساعده في تركيا بالمساعدات الغذائيه
وتوفير الوجبات الساخنه في الفتره القادمه
لما عم نحكي وجبات ساخنه ريم بس عشان افهم
فكره الحصص اللي انتم بتبعتوها هي يوميه
بمعنى اخر ليوم واحد او انه لعده ايام
ممكن تكفيهم الحصص الغذائيه تكفي لمده
سبعه ايام هي لا تحتاج الى
الى طهي ولا تحتاج الى وقود ولا تحتاج الى
كل هذه الاشياء لانه يعلم برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه انا في ظل هذه الظروف هذه
يعني هذه ظروف غير متوفره للعائلات الذين
هم يعني حتى الذين يعيشون في
مناطق الاستضافه للاجئين في تركيا الان
يستضيف هذه ال ال المناطق تستضيف مواطنين
اتراك ايضا
فحجم التحديات وطبيعتها باختصار ريم
بالنسبه لالكم طبعا
الطرقات هي صعبه ولكن الان هناك شاحنات
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه هي متجهه الى
مخيم العثمانيه لسبعه عشر الف شخص بصوره
مبدئيه ولكن سيتم التوزيع تباعا اما ايضا
هناك
بالتعاون مع شركاء البرنامج في الجنوب
التركي الذي ايضا كان له برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في وقت
جاء احد الكوفيد 19 تم تم تفعيل
الوجبات الساخنه من خلال الشركاء وهذا ما
يسعى برنامج الاغذيه العالميه الى تفعيله
وايضا يساعد تسعه محافظات في سوريا طبعا
كلها في عفوا في تركيا كلها في الجنوب
التركي
لمساعده هذه المحافظه
على التوسع في
تقديم الوجبات الساخنه الى المتضررين من
الزلزال الاشخاص الذين فقدوا منازلهم
الاشخاص الذين تجردوا بسبب الازمه الحصص
الغذائيه موجوده ومتوفره او بانتظار
ايصالها ومن خلال المعابر اذا ما تحدثنا
عن سوريا او من خلال المطارات باختصار ريم
معبر باب الهوى الذي يتم من خلاله ايصال
المساعدات الغذائيه عبر الحدود التركيه هو
يعمل ولكن في بطء لانه هناك طبعا
مشكلات بسبب الزلزال ولكن هو يعمل
الان يبحث البرنامج ايضا عن كل الطرق
البديله لايصال المساعد وسنتابع معكم طبعا
التطورات من القاهره ريم ندى المتحدثه
باسم برنامج الغذاء العالمي شكرا جزيلا
على هذه المعلومات نتمنى السلامه ايضا
لفريق العمل على الارض التغطيه مستمره
مشاهدينا على العربيه رجع على راس الساعه
مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا